what was the mental preparation like
for Gordon for Nicholas uh for Giancarlo
for the other athletes what was the
mental side of things like is there some
key insights you can give to their
mental preparation I really think that
people when they talk about mental
preparation need to take a step back and
realize that almost every element of
what people describe as mental
preparation his physical underpinnings
um
literally 95 of what I teach the
athletes is physical skills
and it's my belief that every mental
aspect of competition
the most important which will be
confidence on stage is a direct result
of the the accumulation of physical
skills
people tend to see things like
confidence as a mental state
it is but it comes out of
the performance of physical skills
all my life I've seen Sports
psychologists try to
create confidence in athletes through
non-physical means
and it always ends up being the same
kind of cheesy motivational speeches
um highlight video reels where they try
to pump
artificial confidence into people
and
I've never been impressed by this nor
have I you know have any kind of
positive effect on on Athlete
Performance
what I do see build confidence is the
sense that athletes are developing
skills and using them successfully under
conditions that closely mirror the event
they're preparing for
once they get this down that's where
true confidence comes from confidence
doesn't come from words it comes from
accumulated skills which experience
shows you have
been responsible for successful
performances in the past and if you
accumulate enough of these your
confidence Rises
so
when it comes to the mental aspects of
competition I created a program where
everyone had us was given a set of
skills that they had to work on skills
directly related to what I believe is
the most important elements of success
in ADCC competition
in the gym they accumulated those skills
over time I do it in two different ways
depending on whether these are offensive
skills or defensive skills
for the accumulation of offensive skills
I like to have my athletes work with
athletes who are lesser than themselves
in ability
so that they start to
gain confidence over time just as you
would never send a beginner into a
weightlifting German put 500 pounds on
the bar and tell them to lift it rather
you would start with
a wooden bar then the metal bar and then
gradually accumulate weight over time so
you get a progression and weightlifting
so two and Judith so you don't take a
brand new move and say okay do it on
Gordon Ryan
never going to succeed
uh I have the athletes practice their
offense on Blue belts and work their way
up
defense on the other hand you've got to
start them in the deep end of the pool
so that they start to see what are their
vulnerabilities okay so I put them with
highly competitive athletes at this
start so they can see okay there is a
problem here and then even in defense
they start off with lower belts and
build up their confidence over time
so just as a weightlifter builds up his
ability to build weight sorry to lift
weight over time so to a Jujitsu player
does it by gradually increasing
resistance now in Jiu Jitsu resistance
is not done by weight it's done by skill
level and so over time they started to
accumulate this experience
in time
um they uh we were able to switch off
and have them go against
very very tough athletes each other so
you know uh Luke Griffiths will do a
full power match with Gordon Ryan now
they're fully aware that there's no one
better in the world than Gordon Ryan so
if you have a competitive match with
Gordon Ryan that's a very very healthy
sign so they went from the start where
they were being programmed going against
relatively mild resistance and building
up over time and then building up to the
greatest resistance possible in the
sport of jiu jitsu
and their goal is not to win obviously
but their goal is to provide a
competitive match
now Gordon doesn't have any confidence
issues so for him it's just good hard
competitive training against people that
are
in some ways better than those you'll be
facing in competition for the other guys
it's getting a clear assessment of what
their current skill level is
by going against the best there is
then we add to this a competitive
schedule where the athletes have to go
out into competition so they get used to
the idea of performing in front of
strangers
on stage getting used to the the strange
elements of going out being observed and
judged by people you don't know in a
performance atmosphere and so they were
all given matches in wno competition
leading up to the event uh ADCC trials
local grappling events here in Austin
and given a competitive schedule to
fight and prepare them for ADCC
obviously as ADCC got closer and closer
this was pulled back because of the
danger of injury So within about three
weeks out was the last time we had a
competition
and by this method confidence starts to
grow and uh and so the mental
preparation came out of those physical
underpaints the idea of progressive
resistance increasing over time uh for
both offense and defense building up to
a peak where they're going against the
best athlete in the world so they can
get an accurate assessment of where they
stand once you're given a competitive
match to the best guy in the world you
know damn well that when you go out in
ADCC you're ready to fight anybody
and defense is broadly defined so
defense and
in symmetrical positions like positions
like guard and then defense also
includes escaping from horrible
positions yes
um we're big Believers in the idea of
depth of Defense the idea that uh you
should be able to mount defense all the
way through from early stages based
mostly around anticipation of
identifying danger visually before it
emerges and all the way through to the
deepest levels of Defense where you are
100 defensive and terrible positions and
you have to claw your way out and uh
over time and get back to a neutral
position or even better back to an
attacking position you have an Instagram
post on this topic
um when you get ready to step out for
the biggest moment of your life ask
yourself one question how different is
this really from what I do every day if
the answer is not very different at all
then step forward with confidence and do
we do every day in the same manner and
ignore the hype and distraction you're
ready for action by the way for people
who don't know you need to follow John
donoher Donahue John on Instagram
because uh you have nuggets or large
buckets of nuggets of wisdom often which
is quite profound even bigger than Jiu
Jitsu but anyway so there's some aspect
where you want to mimic the conditions
of your daily training
in um intensity and
in what for So Physical
uh to that of the actual uh mattress you
asked the question about mental training
for me
um the central focus of whatever small
amount of mental training I give my
students comes down to a very very
simple concept to understand this is the
idea of
identifying competition in terms of its
normalcy
most people see training and competition
is two different things training is
normal activity that you do every day
and competition is the exception okay
it's different you're going out there's
people watching you there's a big crowd
they're making lots of noise
um
in fact
the promoters of shows go out of their
way to reinforce this
look at for example ADCC when Gordon
Ryan went to fight Andre Galvan okay do
they just come out on the mat and fight
each other absolutely not this music
there's pageantry there's Fireballs
they're literally shooting Fireballs
yeah some dude in a tie sitting with Joe
Rogan Meathead uh podcast or comedian
whatever uh which one was the meat hit
what well played John Idaho well played
but you see what they're trying to do
they're trying to create theater and
pageantry when in fact it's just a
grappling match it's just two athletes a
referee and a rule set that's that's the
reality
now what they try to sell you is
something which is not reality which is
this is somehow bigger and different
and they reinforce this with pageantry
and theater so that it becomes not just
a grappling match but a grappling
performance the same way you have a
theater performance
and my goal as a coach is to dispel that
and say when you go out there
there's only one reality
you him and the referee reinforcing a
rule set that's it everything else you
see the smoke the fire the music is an
illusion
and it's put there intentionally to make
you feel a certain kind of way and your
whole goal is to see this as an illusion
and walk out and see only the reality
which is that this is the same damn
thing you do every day in the gym
the only difference is you're going with
a guy you've never grabbed before
so the actual act of removing the
illusion or realizing that it is an
illusion
how do you practice that so when you
step on the mat once you're aware of it
I I always have them to you it's like
when you when you see a magician and you
have his tricks explained to you
you never see the magic again the first
time you see a good card trick from a
good magician so my God then when they
explain it to you I did this this and
that step one step two
then you look at it like it's not that
special
and when you explain to people this idea
of the pageantry is an illusion
then just as when you watch the magician
and you learn the trick
all the magic flies out the window so
too with the the nervous response so
that's for the pageantry but what about
the maybe the physical intensity of
competition isn't there
an extra no it's the same in every
competition this it's not like you know
they're twice as strong and 80cc is
there and the ibjf World Championships
it's the physical intensity is always
pretty much the same they experience it
every day in the gym and
um uh like you know if you go out and
you grapple Gordon Ryan it's not like
the next guy who grapple is going to be
twice as strong as hell or twice as fast
this could be a little stronger a little
faster but not so much so that it
completely changes your approach of the
game
um you know there's not that much
difference between the human bodies out
there on stage so if you've felt
intensity before you're not going to be
shocked by ADCC but in terms of in
training
do you have to try to match the
intensity of competition no
um that would be fool should be every
athlete in the gym would be injured uh
you can do it for short periods of time
um but the uh the training has to be
carefully monitored in terms of
intensity levels remember we're training
seven days a week a minimum of twice a
day
um you you've got to keep things under
wraps like you know every other workout
you can have a like one of the five
rounds can be full power but not seven
days a week three times a day that's
that's just gonna break bodies and the
full power is just a reminder
of it's more about skill development for
us it always comes back to school
development but what about matching the
the feeling of the intensity of
competition
so yeah periodically periodically it
can't be rare single time not not really
it's not rare like um meaning like you
know one like out of you know three
hours of hot sparring per day like 15
minutes might be like 100 full power
that way you you that's more than enough
to get psychologically ready for the
intensity of conflict but um uh but
won't break your body over time
intensity of conflict that's well put
there is a competition does doesn't it
have that extra level of animosity
okay it's a little bit more conflict
than it is that can sometimes his
personality differences like for example
like Gordon Ryan and Felipe Pena they
admire each other a lot they respect
each other's skills but they they
certainly don't like love each other
that's for sure so um uh so there can be
certain match up with this more
intensity
um but then there's other matchups where
the two athletes come out and it's
um it's no more intense than a hard
sparring session